[Music]
each flight is just the logic to
save us in the world without Haiti
ambulance
[Music]
who flew with Haiti and Haiti ambulance
wine to make it difficult for my number
to cross the access side with care and
at an easy pace especially
[Music  ]
Melian people
January 12, 2010 and until we
forgive knowledge
and not that we are here to nanter if to
go out outside two three days
later on the sanapouet which damages in
fact
white who installed your mother
[Music]
almost a year and to help me take
to come IMC
and finance
Haiti ambulance in cry in 2014 a
day normal operation it started
even before I have not yet started we
by flown 24 hours a day but it
operational 24 we do not receive calls  and the
juni started from 7 a.m.
because with helicopter
all luggage for a care plan
anyone from illness
the maps make a comparison in two
eras
2021 which capable of we are not
necessary to be anyone
it is for me and  to fly in an
exceptional helicopter or in milk or to fly
which let's try
for myself it's his package of the day
because
thought about it
you supposed gain tens hundreds of
months even who made you work
[Music]
it makes you really happy
[Music  ]